wednesday july 7 edition hiatus style
pft live and pft
pm all the happenings in the nfl even as
we are in
what is the slowest point in the
nfl news cycle but it's never completely
dead there's always something to discuss
and
thanks to aaron rodgers we have
something to discuss because yesterday
if you watched it or like me if you
didn't and
you know i i kind of wanted
to watch it i kind of spent several
weeks preceding
the match under the assumption
that when 5 pm eastern rolled around on
tuesday july 6 i still don't know why
they picked
a tuesday late afternoon i don't get it
but when the time came i didn't want to
watch it didn't care
i figured i would pick up anything
relevant or salient via twitter and
thanks to
multiple twitter accounts i saw the clip
of aaron rodgers about four hours into
the match
being asked by the commentators about
his future
with the green bay packers and he
essentially said
we'll see first he was asked about
whether or not he's going to be at camp
we'll see he was asked about september
12 he was like well what's september 12
oh that's your opening
game against new orleans saints and
again
we'll see and he tried to laugh it off
but
for packers fans it really is getting to
the point where it's no longer
a laughing matter if it ever was and and
and i know this is a strange time if
you're a green bay packers fan because
deep down you are upset by what's
happening
you don't know quite who to be the most
upset with
you're upset with the organization for
making this stupid trade up to get
jordan love when you still have a
perfectly good aaron rodgers one of the
great quarterbacks of all time
you're upset with aaron rodgers for
playing this game and putting
your emotions in the middle of it are
packer is going to have aaron rodgers
are they not going to have him will he
show will he not
show and and the fans are the ones who
who just have to kind of sit and wait
and take it
but at the same time packers fans get
pissed off sorry london
when someone like me points out that
it's a
time when they're understandably
confused frustrated unhappy about what's
going on
well why wouldn't you be it's a normal
human reaction and
and i i don't know where it's going to
go i still think he's going to show up
but here we are now less than three
weeks away from the start of training
camp
and the most recent information from
aaron rodgers about whether or not he's
going to show up
is we'll see we'll see
i guess we will but
packers fans want to know they don't
want to see they want to know
what's going on how hard is it for aaron
rodgers to make it known what he's going
to do and
hey is he still trying to get a trade i
guess i don't know
is he just messing with mark murphy and
brian goodikunst i guess
i don't know but the reality is these
fans he professes to love
the coaches he professes to love the
teammates he
professes to love are caught in the
crossfire here
and for the fans especially i mean the
teammates may know at least some of them
the coaching staff may know
the fans are completely in the dark and
and i feel bad for packers fans they get
mad at me for pointing all this stuff
out i feel bad for you
i'm trying to get this thing resolved so
we all know what the hell is going to go
on
in late july when it's time for aaron
rodgers to show up
or not show up when the browns show up
for training camp it will be a vibe that
we haven't seen in cleveland in a very
long time
if ever at least not since the merger
yes there were years when the browns got
within
shouting distance of the super bowl or
whispering distance as the case may be
if you look at 1986 and 1987
two years ago the expectations were high
they were too high
and that's why i think it was intriguing
that baker mayfield said on tuesday that
managing expectations is going to be one
of the most important things the browns
do this year yes it is
because two years ago they completely
failed to manage expectations
i think the business people with the
browns in 2019
were like hey everybody's taking it
seriously let's go make as much money as
we can let's feed this monster let's
make this a big deal
and then they ended up falling flat and
even though they had a much better year
in comparison to the recent experiences
of the browns it still felt like a
disappointment and a lot of that was on
the head coach
freddie kitchens for not managing
expectations now you've got
baker mayfield saying it and i assume
kevin stefanski the 2020 nfl coach of
the year will be doing it they need to
manage expectations because this thing
will get out of control
the afc is chock full of great
teams it is going to be very difficult
to navigate
the likes of the bills the patriots who
will be much better
the ravens the steelers the titans the
colts
the chiefs the chargers what if aaron
rodgers ends up in denver
then there's another team that is going
to be there
as an impediment for what the browns are
trying to do could they get to the super
bowl
yes a lot of browns fans are thinking
they will
put them in the nfc and i'd say hell
yeah they got a chance to get there in
the afc
that hill is a lot steeper and i think
baker mayfield has it right when he
talks about managing expectations
meanwhile video has emerged of odo
beckham jr professing that it's going to
be a special year that's the kind of
thing that cuts against
the effort to manage expectations
regardless the expectation should be
tempered by the fact
that the browns are stuck
in a great conference and a special
division one of the best in football
what if the bengals have a trick or two
up their sleeve joe burrow healthy as of
week one
you got multiple you got all four teams
it could be potentially in the playoff
conversation and
even though theoretically all four could
make it chances are that's not gonna
happen
so browns first have to get to the
playoffs and then they have to
worry about these great teams that they
will come up against
in january but uh good problem to have
better than looking at your schedule
saying i don't know where the victory is
like the browns were in a couple of
years ago but the super bowl win
still may be off in the distance
somewhere this year could be very hard
to pull it off
the folks that the united states navy
did the right thing on tuesday by
allowing cameron mckinley
i hope i have his name right i don't
know all i've been thinking is the kid
who went to navy
the kid who went to navy we'll get his
name right at some point
anyway the kid who went to navy who
wasn't allowed to go play for the tampa
bay buccaneer see i just assumed maybe
wouldn't change their mind i'd forgotten
all about what his name was but he will
now
be playing for the buccaneers i think
it's cameron kinley there it is cameron
kinley thank you
control room saves me with the topic bar
and fortunately my eye's still good
enough to see
the topic bar cameron kinley allowed to
play for the tampa bay buccaneers
hey as the saying goes wisdom often
never arrives at
all we shouldn't reject it simply
because it showed up late
i still don't like this clunky clumsy
process where
pressure had to be placed on the navy to
do the right thing and allow cameron
kinley
to see now that i remember it i'm going
to say it
as many times as i can cameron kinley
cameron kinley cameron kindly but
he should have been allowed in the first
place he shouldn't have had to go
through this multiple week period
of thinking he wasn't going to be
allowed to
play football before he fulfills his
commitment to the service academy that
he attended
and i don't know why this is so
complicated i don't know why it changes
i don't know why it's a moving target
i think that for anyone who signs
the paperwork that gives them
a free education up front with a
commitment to serve
on the back end the language in there
needs to be clear for each incoming
class
in the event that this individual
displays skills that would attract
professional sports associations to
offer
employment the individual either
yes or no can defer his or her
commitment in order to exhaust those
opportunities
whatever it is you need to know isn't
that fair that's just basic fundamental
stuff
when you say okay i'll go to the naval
academy i'll sign the
the paperwork you know then if it all
works out from a football standpoint
you're going to go
play in the nfl or the nba or wherever
whatever sport you become
someone who is desired by the next level
to participate you can defer your
commitment
and you can go do it i i don't like the
moving target i don't like the fact that
we have to have political pressure to
get people to do the right thing
and there's no reason for the service
academies to not do it because as they
finally realized cameron kinley
said it again becomes a walking talking
breathing
billboard for going to the naval academy
because now it's it's i don't know maybe
maybe they played this game to make it a
bigger story but they looked
bad in the process they got to the right
place
but but they were in the wrong place for
a while
i look it's it's free publicity but i
don't know that's a publicity you want
because they come off as doofus and they
come off as ultimately giving in
to the pressure to do the right thing
but it is
a great advertising and recruiting
mechanism they should want
their athletes who become potential
professional prospects
to go and represent the organization
well
and get more kids out there who have
high levels
of football basketball baseball soccer
whatever talent
to say i'll go to the service academy
they'll let me pursue my professional
dreams and then i'll come back and serve
whenever i'm done why not do that for
everyone and why not have a consistent
cohesive policy that applies
not just to cameron kinley but to every
athlete
male or female that ends up attending
any of the service academies
2019 last pick in round one after the
new england patriots won super bowl 53
went to receiver
nikhil harry at the time there was a
belief that the patriots had him
rated even higher than number 32 and now
it's falling apart and the evidence has
been there from the moment the patriots
launched free agency by signing a couple
of tight ends
signing a couple of receivers nikhil
harry
looking like he's on shaky ground
there's been persistent reports and
rumors that
the patriots may cut him that he may
just not even
be there and now his agent instead of
being fired
wants his guy to be able to quit via a
trade i don't know that anyone's going
to trade for it
with with the last two years of a
first-round rookie contract and yes it's
number 32
so it's it's lower money than it would
be if it was number two
but that's a seven figure commitment
each of the next two years that a team
would take on if they trade for his
contract i don't know that anyone's
going to want to do it i think at the
end of the day the patriots may just
have to cut him
regardless the broader point maybe the
patriots should just give up
drafting receivers in the first three
rounds i look back over the past 20
years yeah dion branch in 2002 a third
round pick ended up being a super bowl
mvp
the rest of maybe he was a second round
pick either way round two or round three
i
i
round three is what's sticking out in my
brain plenty of second round picks
third round picks and nikhil harry
the first first round pick that the
patriots used on a receiver since terry
glenn
before bill belichick was the head coach
harry just hasn't worked out and the
guys on the board
when they picked harry included terry
mclaurin d.k metcalf aj brown
debo samuel no guarantee any of those
guys would have worked out
because here's the reality it's easy to
say
the patriots are picking the wrong guys
but it's not like they are
reaching for guys that no one has ever
heard of
no one's saying for example when the
patriots take nikhil harry
well he's a fifth round prospect on you
know 28 other boards
they're just like yeah okay nikhil harry
it was time for him to be drafted so if
it wasn't the patriots someone else
would have taken him the question is
how are the patriots developing
something sims and i have talked about
in the past
how much of it is the coaching staff not
properly
teaching the coaching staff not trusting
the coaching staff not being patient
that
it's sink or swim and at the first sign
of sync
they go with someone that they know can
swim because that guy's been in the nfl
for multiple years he's been around the
block he knows the ropes
i i think that's one of the potential
problems and when it comes to drafting
this is a point sims has made the
patriots will
often prioritize intangibles like
leadership and love of the game
over raw ability well sometimes you end
up in
a mess like this because you you looked
too heavily
at what kind of a guy you were getting
and you didn't look enough at what kind
of a player
you were getting regardless it's not
working for the patriots
at the receiver position and
either they fix it or they just sign
veterans and
the way the receiver position is going
with so many great receivers coming out
every year there will be a glut
of free agents every year and that may
be the better way for the patriots to
handle it
if they're not willing or able to
develop a young receiver let someone
else develop the young receiver and then
you
pay him especially because the receiver
position is becoming a lot like the
running back position where there are
more great ones than the teams out there
need let's answer a question or two
before we wrap up this wednesday edition
of pft live pftpm hiatus style
sunny tsunani do you think aaron rodgers
is bothered by all the smack talk from
tom brady considering his
nfc buddy brady is dunking on him on and
off the field even though rogers won the
golf mask
yesterday or is this all a carefully
crafted facade to relay rogers messages
i kind of like the idea i mean this is
super genius
stuff where aaron rodgers has asked tom
brady
to poke fun at rogers to help rogers
make his point to the packers
that's really next level that's evil
genius stuff
i don't think brade why is brady want to
help what what's in it for brady
to help aaron rodgers get whatever it is
he wants unless brady thinks
hey if i can get this guy out of the
conference why not get him to denver
i don't have to deal with him i worry
about him in the super bowl
and if it's either him or patrick holmes
or lamar jackson or josh allen i gotta
deal with a great quarterback there
anyway if we get back to the super bowl
my path the super bowl is easier if i
can get aaron rodgers out of the
conference i think that's giving
everyone too much credit i think brady's
just having fun
and aaron rodgers is going along with it
but based on what we've learned about
rogers over the past decade
i suspect at some level he's not real
thrilled with being made fun of about
anything and uh
yeah he probably doesn't appreciate all
the barbs from tom brady but what's he
going to say to tom brady stop it
no because if you do you're only making
the situation worse the best thing you
can do
when someone's giving you a hard time
about something that is rubbing you raw
don't act like it is don't let them know
that it is or they will
not stop mark pankhurst
do you think that with lamar jackson not
having an agent that opens it up for him
and ravens gm eric decosta to go for the
option of a percentage of the salary cap
with or without incentives tied to it
i've been a big proponent
of quarterbacks agreeing to
a percentage of the salary cap in order
to ensure that they are
always paid at an appropriate level
because the cap keeps going up except
for this year but this year was an
aberration the cap will continue
to go up and up and up and up through
this decade the percentage
of a guy like patrick mahomes of the cap
is going to drop
why not just say franchise quarterback
is always guaranteed to get 18
of the total cap whatever the cap may be
i don't think that's going to happen
with lamar jackson number one because
it's never happened with anyone else
number two i don't think the league
wants teams to do it
and the management council has a way of
getting its point across
when the time comes to let
teams know what is and isn't frowned
upon even though it's perfectly
permissible to give quarterbacks a
percentage of the cap
i just don't see the planets lining up
that way with any of these guys
if dak prescott didn't get it from the
cowboys and he got a great deal
if he didn't get it from the cowboys
when he had maximum leverage
right now jackson baker mayfield josh
allen they do not have maximum leverage
the only guy that's going to have a
chance to get a percentage of the cap
is a guy who either hits the open market
or who has his current team over a
barrel
such that the team will do whatever the
guy wants to keep the guy
from saying no i'm not going to accept
your offer so
i think someday someone will do it but
we're not quite there
yet and we're definitely not there with
lamar jackson tony wheat
do you think at some point some of the
beth wilkinson findings in the
washington football team investigation
will actually leak
if so what next well point i made the
other day
and hey i gotta give the nfl credit
brilliant evil genius stuff like we were
talking about earlier
the way that they dropped that the way
that they handled it i thought it would
resonate into the week
after fourth of july it really has not
now
it may be a delayed reaction i don't
know but
the point i made in something that we
posted on sunday or monday
beth wilkinson's files still exist
unless someone has told her to expunge
them
the findings that she made the
interviews that she conducted
communication she had among her
colleagues everything that led to the
oral report that was given to the nfl
there's something tangible out there
somewhere
lawyers create and save data that's what
they do and anytime someone starts
deleting that data you have to start
wondering what's going on so
i think that there's plenty of evidence
out there
now with someone from beth wilkinson's
firm who's frustrated by the way this is
handled
put some information together and leak
it that that i i don't know
that there was some stuff that was
leaked to 1067 the fan
a couple of months ago at a time when
the belief was wilkinson's team was
frustrated by
the fact that the nfl appeared poised to
not really do all that much about it
that was the theory at the time i don't
know whether or not that's accurate
but leaks could happen the other way the
information come out civil litigation
and lisa banks and deborah katz
represent more than 40 former employees
if they file suit if they're within the
relevant statute of limitations if their
deadline hasn't run
they can file suit and if they don't
settle if the thing ends up in court at
some point that evidence could come out
beth wilkinson could testify she could
be required to produce all documents
from her files to show what's in there
and a lot of that stuff could make its
way into the public eye i've pointed out
that if there's a congressional
subcommittee that gets curious about
this
they could have a hearing they could
subpoena documents they could subpoena
witnesses some of the evidence could
come out that way and then ultimately
a prosecutor that has jurisdiction over
the washington football team's offices
they could look at roger goodell's
findings and say this is troubling there
may be some
criminal violations that have occurred
here let's convene a grand jury
let's have beth wilkinson testify let's
find out how deep that rabbit hole goes
the fact that they've refused to even
give us a glimpse of
it suggests that there's stuff in there
that as tanya snyder was quoted as
saying last week
would be mortifying see i think that's
ultimately the game here
you keep the specific information from
coming to light and you
avoid the public pressure the same kind
of pressure that was placed on the navy
to do the right thing with cameron
kinley
the pressure that would be placed on the
nfl to force daniel snyder to sell if we
never have
the ability to sink our teeth into
the evidence that resulted in the
findings
that were summarized in very general
fashion by the commissioner
we never have anything we can point to
to say god i can't believe this happened
this is unacceptable daniel snyder must
sell or look at this i can't believe
that happened this is unacceptable
daniel schneider must sell it comes to
life it's the equivalent of the ray rice
elevator video
the point i made last week by not even
having a report created the nfl in this
case
put a baggie over the camera before the
video could even be created
and i think that's where we are whether
or not that video gets created in some
other context
we shall see all right let's see i think
i saw one more i wanted to ask oh
her answer excuse me s herbert greetings
from houghton regis uk
can you see the london games happening
this season with the dual covert rules
set by the nfl
uh i i know that some of the fans in the
uk are concerned because
the last i heard the tickets weren't on
sale yet for the games
now i checked with the nfl the nfl said
everything's on track and they're
planning to play two games
in london this year but by now the
understanding i get from the folks that
that communicate with us who watch pft
live in the uk the understanding i get
is that that the tickets haven't been
put on sale yet and that there's some
reason
to be concerned so i i don't know
the nfl's position as of a couple of
weeks ago is everything is fine and
everything is moving forward so we'll
see how that
plays out last one the vikings gazette
how would you define success for the
minnesota vikings in 2021 well you know
every team would say we define success
by whether or not we win the super bowl
but that's not true
they define success by how much money
they make and they make the most money
as i said yesterday by
acting like they have every intent to do
everything they can to win the super
bowl this year though
to keep people employed to avoid the
kind of of potential
changes that the wolf family may make
they have to get to the playoffs
i don't know that they have to win a
game or two
it probably would be very helpful to at
least get to the divisional round
but i think playoffs if they don't get
to the playoffs this year
i think major changes will be happening
in minnesota because
if they fail to get there after the
money they've spent in free agency
the the resources they've put into the
offense the decision to
let clint kubiak take over for gary
kubiak and keep the same system
when you look at the talent that they've
amassed if this isn't good enough to get
one of the seven playoff spots in
a conference that isn't nearly as
competitive as the afc
if they can't get to the playoffs this
year something isn't working
and something needs to be blown up sir
so
uh success
well again it's always a super bowl win
ultimate success super bowl win
a season they could feel good about at
least the final eight
if not the final four but you know the
vikings have been to the final four i
think seven
times since the last time they made
super bowl and for all their struggles
in the super bowl 0-4
they have yet to win an nfc championship
game in the various times they've been
back since the last time they went to
the super bowl so
i don't know that this is the year but
when you look at the nfc
other than the buccaneers there really
isn't a team that stands out as a
powerhouse so maybe this is the year the
vikings get back to the super bowl and
lose their fifth one
that year is coming in my lifetime they
will get back
and lose their fifth one because i
guarantee you when they get back
especially if they get back this year
they will lose their fifth one
so what's better vikings fans
to have a chance to go one and four or
to know you're going to end up owing
five
who knows is that success i don't know
but that's all i have to say about that
and that's all i have to say today we'll
do it again tomorrow
thanks for some of your time check us
out around the clock at
profootballtalk.com and as always we
appreciate your input we appreciate
your participation and we will talk to
you again very soon
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports